foreign
Liz is in Boston hi Liz welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
um yeah so I'm calling
um with sort of it's two questions that
kind of go into one so
um I'm getting four thousand dollars
back on our tax returns and I'm gonna
pay off a credit card with that and I
have another credit card that I do need
to pay off but I also have a small
business and I was wondering
what your thoughts are on putting that
money toward um as an investment into my
small business
um I have a food blog so I was thinking
of doing a website audit to see if I
could increase my website traffic
um you know to make more money off of
ads and things like that and um to go
along with that question I am a
stay-at-home mom and I guess I'm just
wondering if um I guess I'm just
wondering if I'm doing the right thing
being a stay-at-home mom
um I left my job as a physical therapy
assistant
um three years ago and I have two
children under the age of two
um I work 10 hours a week
um actually from my website host and
then next we bought on the side and I
just wasn't sure if I'm doing the right
thing okay what do you make on the 10
hours a week
35 an hour okay so 350 bucks okay and
then what are you making on the food
block
not a lot
of coffee for that on the side and then
um some months it's you know close to
like 50. okay no you do not put four
thousand dollars into that
okay take you forever to get it back
yeah you're not making enough to justify
a four thousand dollar investment you're
making enough to justify a 400
investment yeah yeah it would be it
it's too much
okay I'm also gonna
poke a larger beer here you said you're
a stay-at-home mom I'm assuming you're
married
yes what's he make
um this year it'll end up being about
240.
okay so what's the problem yeah I I
think I know what the problem is because
you're saying these are your your tax
return your credit cards you guys don't
have your money combined
no we don't
um we do in a sense that
um he pays all of the bills and I pay my
student loans and my credit cards
um yeah so you're not combined
no
we do have it we do have a joint account
um you're not combined dear
I know what you're saying I know you
want it to sound better than what it is
but you're not combined but I hear from
your voice that maybe you would like to
be
yeah um
I think it would be a little less
stressful
um
yeah so let me here's the thing
this man
has a wife
and two babies
his job is not to make his wife pay her
student loans so she can take care of
the two children that he sired
that's bullcrap
all right so the two of you should put
all of your money in a pile and the two
of you should take care of the two of
you for sickness and sickness and in
health for richer for poorer and the old
wedding vows back in the day the old
book of common prayer writing vows say
unto thee all my worldly Goods I pledge
you're good enough to have babies with
but not good enough to have your student
loans taken care of bull crap
yeah you took him if he gets sick you're
gonna make him chicken soup
and you got student loans so we have two
children we have student loans we made
the decision for you to be a
stay-at-home mom because that's what you
wanted to do and you're fretting over
eighteen hundred dollars and fifteen
hundred dollars while your husband makes
a quarter of a million dollars a year
bull crap have you brought this up to
him before that it would be a lot less
stressful if you guys could just combine
your money
um yeah it's it has been a conversation
it was never like really
um stressed like I never really
um okay tried to make it like a big
Point
um
I guess I feel guilty he has no debt and
I have like no he's married you
you you come with all of you you married
him
he doesn't he doesn't walk around
feeling guilty about being selfish no
you don't need to walk around feeling
guilty about dadgum student loans I'm
not gonna look I'm not gonna I'm
catching a Vibe here that I don't like
at all and
Dave is right that's all I can say I
don't want to jump to any conclusions
I'm catching a Vibe I don't like I don't
like that you have all this guilt
surrounding a simple request I don't
like that you are feeling so much
apprehension about having this
conversation with this man that you're
married to and have three kids with so
there's a lot going on here
um
if you're good enough to have babies
with you're good enough to combine
finances with yeah yeah okay I mean I
think he would be open to it
um good that would speak highly of him
I I would think better of him than I do
I would too because I think I think you
guys are just plowing along and hadn't
stopped and looked at this maybe so
let's stop and look at it because here's
the thing you're fretting over stuff
that you guys want to just write check
pay these loans off I'm guessing you got
the money in the bank and you ought to
clear them up it's not up to you to do
it by yourself any more than it's up to
you to feed the children by yourself or
it's up to you to uh do everything by
yourself it's not up to him to do
everything by himself okay so we we are
a team that's what we said when we went
to the altar we are a team we are a team
we are a team we both have a vote and we
both bring strengths and we both bring
weaknesses to the team we are a team we
are a team we are a team and let me just
tell you the people that build the
highest quality marriages with the
highest probability of extreme
Prosperity meaning Building Wealth and
becoming baby steps millionaires all the
data points to they work together and
they combine their finances well I want
to be independent well you should not
gotten married because when you get
married by definition you are not
independent anymore you don't have to
lose your personal identity right and
and this is not some kind of 1950s thing
I'm talking about here I'm giving you
fresh data from the marketplace that
says folks you need to combine your
finances if you're willing to combine
your bed
not any more than that I mean in terms
of being married okay so it's time it's
time you have babies together you can
pay off Finance so you can pay off
student loans together